[Music]
oh for some people to get in here
is that people i don't see any people
we got a person slack thank you hello
what's up
hi everybody how you doing
thank you thank you we are
live on location in telluride colorado
um and
i'm here to show to you
the comma 2 sale now it's not so easy to
use
you're gonna have to solve a little
puzzle so hopefully you guys
solve the puzzle um
yeah yeah i'm staying cool outside
california that's right that's right
it's uh
it's 120 degrees in palm springs
i have never felt so much heat in my
life
i'm speaking about things that are hot
you guys should check out our labor day
sale
it is the first sale ever on the comma
two
you can save 100 uh if you solve the
puzzle
if you don't solve the puzzle you don't
save 100 it's as simple as that
um we'll have to repeat again when we
get a few more people in here
cheap comma 2 that's right you're never
going to see a comma 2 this cheap again
probably till like next labor day or
july 4th
um so today is the day
to get your purchases in
um the answer is not 42 you're close
though you're close
a little higher than 42 a little higher
um so we're in beautiful telluride
colorado
um i would say 95 of my drive here was
open pilot
um oh you got you guys got to check out
this mountain behind me oh look at this
look at this mountain there's a there's
a gondola on the mountain
it is not 69 no no no
um that is that is also wrong yo let's
go let's go walk over there we're going
to go check out that mountain
um oh
we're not here to talk about that we're
here to talk about the labor day
sale on the comma 2.
can a vision based system be better than
a fully attentive human yes of course it
can
um
is there smoke in the air from the fires
yeah yeah i think that's what it was
um but so guys you know i was gonna show
some driving footage
but unfortunately the uh reception
while you're driving is really spotty um
i'm in the hyundai sonata 2020. uh you
guys i think the story's live for
another couple hours on my instagram
if you want to see i posted a nice open
pilot picture also check out the song on
the radio
yeah that's the smoke right we are still
hiring uh email
just commenting jobs or email give me a
job a comment ai
we are aggressively hiring but you got
to be a genius because that's the rule
be a genius come work at com ai and
don't get hit by that truck
um you know if that truck had open pilot
i know
bob doesn't see pedestrians always pay
attention level two system
um yo
just look look at this look at this look
at this mountain behind us
zero eight is on its way uh
we're gonna have we're gonna there's
gonna be a little ui change up in zero
eight not a big ui change up just a
little ui change up
i think you guys are gonna love it um
make sure to get your comma two
while it's cheap uh because you're gonna
be like damn you know i should have
bought it while it was cheap not while
it was expensive
uh so you know this is hashtag ad i'm
being paid by comma to do this not
really
i really don't get paid [ __ ] when i'm
traveling but other than that
um i wouldn't chill for a product that i
didn't really believe in
you know that you know that you know if
i wouldn't drive out here with my very
own karma two
uh i wouldn't be i wouldn't be shilling
for it but you know i love road trips
and it's really a nice um
companion maybe that's the word
companion
uh yeah so we can't make this live
stream only five minutes we'll do like a
couple minutes of questions and then
i'm gonna go find lunch hopefully
there's lunch
i hope there's lunch driving through
arizona there's no lunch
what's up um now but today uh one day
only
get a discount on the commentary you're
gonna have to solve a puzzle
um and i will give you guys a hint right
here just in this live stream
if you want to know how many cars open
pilot supports go on the github
and count them count the number of rows
and the tables
uh count the number of rows if you guys
didn't figure that out
oh how's mu zero driving coming along
it's all right that's all right um
hopefully we made an offer to someone on
friday hopefully they accept they're
gonna come help with the
new zero driving project uh this isn't a
life advice stream
this is an ad for the savings
on the comato uh just today today only
you can save
100 you know
figured since this labor day you guys
know i love america
um if you're near by omaha hey reverend
no i'm not near omaha man i'm in
telluride colorado
uh you want to join with rotterdam we no
we don't do research on rotterdam open
pile team at rotterdam
research team in san diego
yeah i know once to solve driving you'll
have an institution with the general
ability to solve problems i pointed at
next
world hunger nah nah we'll point it at
you know we're gonna point it out we're
gonna point it at the uh
the [ __ ] greedy bankers man we're
gonna we're gonna all day all week
occupy wall street but like you know
good right
that sound reasonable i don't know i'm
here in colorado
we're gonna go walk off over over we're
gonna walk over a bridge
over we're gonna go walk over bridge
great place for corn on the cob what do
we got what do we got
uh 2020 rav4 prime i think i read there
were some issues with that but i'm sure
they're software not hardware
um so we could just
fix that someone can fix it you know all
the code is open source
it was always one thousand dollars
except for today when you can get it
for 8.99 if you
uh use the discount code yeah
oh this is oh it's private oh i'm sorry
boys
i'm gonna walk across this beautiful
bridge but it's it's a private bridge
so what's the margin on it no i'm not
making [ __ ] you know
this this is almost that cost so you got
my fingers crossed
uh no a for-profit company man uh no but
these things are real pain to make
uh i believe we do support the kia
telluride i think one of our employees
may have purchased a key italia ride
actually
uh so that's gonna be very well labor
day means we work extra hard hell yeah
hell yeah it's a day to celebrate hard
labor
um well zero eight work with white panda
no white pandas are
over bye bye pandas bye bye white pandas
gray pandas
gonna be over soon um we support our
hardware for one year
after something new or has been solved
so once something newer comes out
have you ever seen a cama harness fail
yeah probably we've sold thousands of
them
you know one percent failure rate is
sick and that still means
like 20 harnesses failed 30 horses
failed
um yo should we ride the gondola we can
go to san sophia
and mountain village i saw a sign for
mountain village on my way down here
explore telluride let's see what we got
we might get on the gondola in here
gondola stream
um anymore any more open pilot questions
any more questions about the discount
who solved the puzzle who solved it
already
um no interest in gta it's
you can't we can't uh we can't repackage
it we can't run it in uh
nci carl is our main simulator
um the puzzle yeah
you guys go on our twitter uh and you'll
see about the puzzle
and you solve the puzzle you save one
hundred dollars on your comma two now
you see the puzzle yeah
uh you can now mask sir oh wait no no no
this is an official comedy channel
uh you can judge for yourself
um it is not dodrio
no some people have masks
sue me man sue me if i go to jail in
colorado it'll be like outlaws in the
old west
um oh vision ipc had some issues we're
working on it
oh you put a comment too in the car just
you can check the answer you get the
answer right
don't tell anyone the answer uh failure
rate for c2s
uh we have a one year warranty uh
they're getting you know the early ones
had some issues the new one the ones
being built now are a lot better
um i mean you see them on discord too
remember that we have sold multiple
thousands
of them so you know if you see 30 people
in the discord
you know having issues well
it's still like one percent
looking like a little nas yeah
nah i've been uh listening to some
philosophy books those are the stranger
audible the stream is not brought to you
by audible
unlike a lot of other streams uh we're
gonna do the trial next
but interspersed with some david sedaris
you know i can't just listen to music
the whole time
but yeah open pilot road trip um i don't
know i haven't heard grime's
argument all right this one doesn't say
private we can walk on this bridge
check out this bridge this is pretty
nice bros
no fool by randomness
but yeah humans like to see patterns and
things where they don't exist
more frequently now it's a labor day hat
you guys want to oh audible speed
multiplier i got it on 1.3
we are literally wired to find patterns
well 1.7 us where what's intelligent
hopefully some lunch no i won't drop the
phone
i got two hands on my phone ripping it
all right any other questions about the
sale
labor day sale i wish i wish i could
have streamed with you guys while i was
driving but the reception up here is
just too spotty and it would cut out
and you would think that that reflects
on the quality of the product which it
absolutely does not
it's an incredible product do i know
meditation yeah
yeah it's meditating this morning
is it the hat is that why i look
different i'm wearing a hat
yeah yeah i sat i sat cross-legged on a
tree stump
that was pretty cool
thank you um
but uh guys you know what we're trying
to get we're trying to get our uh
and fat oh who's getting bad
um
no no no this is this is a work related
stream got to keep things work related
self-driving cowboy
look there's someone behind me
uh all right what else we got we'll make
it go to make it go to 15 or 20 minutes
or something
we got a beautiful stream over here to
our left
how long until level four i don't know
ah we'll see maybe we'll do lex friedman
again
um i don't know you can't you know
i'm just thinking of the marshall
matters lp2 where he says gonna
recapture the magic and like
you know it's just you can never capture
the magic once the magic's gone the
magic is gone and that's just
how magic works
uh how long until level four
level three is going to happen first
next
product autonomous horse
oh i found a lake there's a lake
maybe oh let's go sit by this stream oh
that sounds nice
yeah the first podcast is good it's one
of my better pieces of content
oh perfect i can put the stream in the
background
um if you guys don't have i mean how
many of you already have comma twos
raise your hand if you already have a
comato
stream by the stream yeah
who's missing a comma two who still
lacks a comato
what could i tell you right now to get
you
into a brand new comma two
you got one your car doesn't work with
it jonathan what car you got
you have panda white panda white silver
man
um buy you a car or a vw it should
support vw's
i comment three who's heard of a comment
three we're selling comma twos
um everything's obsolete in two years
haven't you seen like the future
you know i'm here on an iphone 11 pro i
can't wait till that 12 comes out
i had a dream last night about buying an
ipad because i heard some sick things
about the new processor
but then i was like i'm gonna wait for
the new arm macbook cause it's gonna
have that sick processor um i don't
really know why ipads were in my dream
but they were
all right we'll go to 20. go to 20
minutes
20 minute ad what what what could
i you have panda blue i don't know what
that is
uh you drive ford focus i mean white
panthers are still good for other stuff
they just don't work with open pilot
anymore we need that high precision gps
to
keep you locked on in curves
um you're just here for the startup
review what's the startup view
i have high hopes of the art macbook
yeah
um would i be interested in building a
new social media platform
no
zuk's is over man got bought by amazon
now bezos you know got a rocket company
at a car company
uh holds the car to one lane when the
other lane disappears yeah that's that
at the end
you guys know new models are coming in
zero eight new models have
four lanes and two road edges so
hopefully we're gonna display those
things
in the ui avx is stupid especially the
x512
that's not what an x86 chip is um
and then for the zero eight series we're
going to really push on end to end
longitudinal
i was thinking i was uh coming up behind
a car at a uh
at a at a red light and like i don't
like the way it stays so
tight behind the lead car even when
there's a red light there but the only
way to really do that is holistically
because you can have the same lead car
state it's just the color of the light
that determines your policy
end and longitudinal will solve these
you can do navigation with what
no i'm not going to virtual ces virtual
ces is lame
virtual anything is lame um
yeah yeah we're here representing
america labor day there is nothing
more american than working
another simulator stream yeah maybe
covetously
to convert old cars someone else can do
it i mean someone else should do it and
just build it on our platform
that's i tell the x-matic guy that's
what he should do you know he could
actually sell like you know probably a
thousand of them
um but nope
no go go send an email to the xmatica he
has the kit
labor date means you work double the
hours edie long for the bosch boys yeah
yeah yeah
well once we go radarless
um you kind of need anton long to go
radarless
i'm very we're very excited about the
rtx 3000s
um xmatic they're a
canadian company you know they have
ideas that they're going to compete with
us they should just play in our
ecosystem
but um you keep trying to compete with
me like i can play in our ecosystem
ghost why don't you just make hardware
for comma ai you know play in our
ecosystem come join
come join come come into our ecosystem
uh we're thinking 30
80s actually um
because 3090s are overpriced to take up
three slots
oh the multiple camera question oh the
multiple camera question
ah dgx is stupid
so overpriced so overpriced
you wanna you wanna buy you know what
man i'm gonna take something i'm gonna
make it gold-plated and then i'm gonna
charge
5x for it wanna buy a gold-plated comma
two five g's
but on labor day i sell it here for 4
500. i know that dog's having a good
time
um i don't know ati needs to get their
software together what's the labor day
sale
the labor day sale is
dude if you can sell a concept for 70k
do it concepts are worthless i don't
know what sucker's going to pay you
um yeah i know the dog right
um you would contact me directly well
you can buy phone calls comment i slash
services
uh will i have a shop in europe what do
you mean by a shop
or should we ship from the europe office
uh the europe office doesn't do that the
urban office just does software
development
you know they have like a lot of laws
over there this is america
we have a reasonable amount of laws
rockham is so bad i mean maybe they'll
fix it maybe they'll fix it
amd if you want to put me in charge of
that project
i'd love to stick it to one video
for new hires do you look more at scale
at ability or work experience and
education
i look for skill and motivation
gotta have skills and you gotta be
motivated
that's it
it's a nice stream
red meat and core is light it's a good
diet
elon talked about my video on twitter oh
yeah yeah the open dojo one yeah
stream on stream this is a stream stream
we'll sit we'll sit this way so you guys
can have a different a different
background
we're on location i swear this is not a
zoom screen
oh best beer
bud light man
thank you
uh i did see mercedes claim of level
three autonomous
and all that makes me think is of audi's
claim of level three autonomous and it
was fake
for future car buyers toyota better
hyundai you're going to have a good
experience in a corolla
um but you'll also have a good
experience in a hyundai it's not as a
nicer car
costs a bit more uh internships in
europe i don't know
willem's in charge of that office you'll
have to ask him i don't know if he wants
to do interns or not
um
you love hyundais yeah
all right this isn't a generic stream
this is a comma stream this is an
official comma stream
on an official comma channel so we've
got to keep it official
uh toyota's layout you mean how hyundai
has eight different connectors
what why do i need depth do you use
depth
can you drive with one eye hmm i don't
know
i think you can react to mercedes ai
video
that's probably terrible and lame i
don't know i haven't seen it maybe it'll
surprise me you know
i always want to be surprised i always
want to be surprised level three in
three years
yeah i'm hopeful i'm hopeful we're
setting a reasonable target that we
believe we can achieve
elon's doing shield streams now it's
changing the future
i'm telling you in like 2032
the presidential candidate whoever wins
the u.s presidency is gonna livestream
the whole thing
ah they're gonna be a streamer that's
what i think
gave up on slim now we use slam
internally to recover state
but then we just predict the state
directly with a neural net
our first tick-tock president not too
back sucks
and is banned banned for sucking
okay thank you all for joining my stream
make sure to go and
purchase a comment too today or actually
you know what
do me a favor and don't purchase it
today purchase it
tomorrow because tomorrow
we make an extra hundred dollars off of
you yeah
i mean i don't know i don't want you to
save money
no i would never sell for a billion i'm
selling for 2 billion
two b's someone's gonna one day contact
me seriously i'd be like i'll give you
two b's and then i'm like
all right cool thanks bro that's what i
was looking for and then i'm out
uh two b's buy me out um
waiting for tc what's a tc i've never
heard of a tc like a ttz fly
like you mean what ari gold said you
know it's like the key word to get out
of the agency
titsy fly sell out two billion
that's right why not do a spec so lame
um
kami and i planning on becoming public
soon no i don't really like that whole
aspect of the business we don't really
do any of that
we're just gonna make open pilot better
and better and better and better
two billion i've always said two billion
uh what would i do with two billion
dollars give it a charity man
i don't care i don't need the money but
i just like the idea you know
you know that's right i beat cruz and i
beat zuke's
um and by the way we built something
incredible open source that'll be
open source forever nah nah
199 billion not two only two two b's
um thank you vegas
now i'm gonna donate it to like some
ridiculous cause you know
masks for hamsters what would masks for
hamsters do if we got a
they got a two billion dollar cash
infusion
ah have we had offers yet yeah i don't
know i wouldn't sell to anyone
for 2 billion if i thought they were
really lame-o in the salt of them
no but yeah like you know some car
company they decide they seriously want
to win
two billion maybe
maybe should i demand open pilots stay
open source too
we'll see we'll see we'll see how it
goes
um you know every release it gets better
uh
when you're climbing out of a hole if
every night
if every day you climb up three feet and
every night you slide
down too you're still eventually going
to get to the top of the hole
possible twitch road trip stream nah
nah this is not this is a private road
trip for me
and me and some of my instagram
followers but
um nah i'm coming into denver tonight
maybe tomorrow got some friends in
denver
and hang out
i was gonna shoot fall guys yeah yeah
yeah there's official comic stream we're
not here to talk about that stuff
would i create an open pilot kit for
tesla with ap two and three you won't
believe how bad it is in europe
you don't even need a kit to be honest
you could probably install open pilot on
the driving computer
of course i drive the alpha builds i
haven't seen any fires but i have seen
smoke and you know what they say
let me smoke this fire
all right all right i'm serious this
time it really only will be a 30 minute
stream
i know the followers have been growing
but uh the viewers
but twitch did not accept my proposal
but they didn't decline my proposal
either the proposal is in purgatory
which i am not i'm in telluride
purgatory is over there
um
how long will the recruitment process
take for what
i don't know that game and nintendo's
yeah we could make it work i don't know
someone can do it
hello uh no more trade-ins nope but
today you can save 100 uh
if you buy it am i in texas now i'm in
colorado
the fifth free estate according to the
cato institute
uh can you download the apk for comma
prime uh yeah go to one of those like
apk finds i'm sure it's on there
why don't you get through the store uh
well we can put a link on our website
too
for the apk
um what do i think about elon thinking
autopilot improves exponential with data
it's a
total [ __ ] not only is their system
not fully learning
based it's actually the other way around
you get exponentially more data for
linear improvement
um and elon knows this too so you know
exponential growth sounds good though
right like that tesla stock
i don't know if it's up i sold i sold at
the peak uh hopefully
the peak i want to get back in but you
know
2 500 a share it's a little high
oh yeah
yeah i made a lot of money yeah common
pencil update project's going well
uh the new segnets have really low
losses
um it's great to see community coming
together like that
we hired a company to to to help speed
it up it's after split now i don't know
i still think of before split
my mom was like you know i i used to
only have
x shares of tesla but now i have five x
shares of tesla i'm like mom
it's the same
she's like no but now you can buy it for
less money i'm like robin hood aurelie
lets you buy fractional shares
and then she was like yeah but only kids
use robin hood and i was like yeah
that's true
um okay thank you all for watching today
is the
one chance for you to get 100 off a
comma 2.
you're probably you're really not going
to see this deal again this year
probably not for most of next year
either so this is this is your chance
just ordered it that's what i like to
hear thank you all for watching
drive safe everybody enjoy life
love nature thank you all for watching